i don't think anyone saw this one coming
what do you think when you first look at
ted lasso
a winner one hell of a dancer fearless
the first guy to die
in a zombie flick a stash but would you
play for this guy
i want to play for anyone that
celebrates victories like a guy who just
found out the open bar to winning has
been extended the thing that coach lasso
excels at
is dispensing wisdom whether through a
metaphor or quoting dead philosophers
that fella looked like a kitty cat when
you get spooked by a cucumber
my thing as a player is does the coach
know the game
could you explain the offside rules well
trey i'm gonna put it the same way the
u.s supreme court did back in 1964 when
they defined pornography
it ain't easy to explain but you know
when you see it so how are the fans
going to take to ted lasso in the uk
fans are passionate over here and they
drink more way more so
every wrong move is going to get
scrutinized and also brush up on some of
our lingo
especially the swear words let's see we
got here
wanker he's gonna need to develop some
thick skin trust me ted lasso has thick
skin once i went to a game and the
students were chanting the coach's
social security number
ninety percent of coaching is keeping
the lines of communication
open with your players wait is that
marriage
my door is always going to be open all
right you can ask me anything door is
always open
i like that like hey coach listen i
can't make practice because i'm hosting
an international ping-pong tournament
in my backyard sorry coach she made me
an appointment
getting waxed but what makes ted a
success
is even when his teams lose they'll take
a look around the room and say
we may have gotten our nips kicked in
but let's stuff our face with cake
that's a guy any player will go to
[Music]
battle
you